foreign
drop of my blood could change everything
[Music]
free people from sickness and death
two hours passed since the procedure
subject deceased
it happened while no one was watching
like roots and
vampires
that's what these monsters became
all we know so far is that this started
with Avon
company of parasites were the thirst for
immortality
[Music]
bit by bit the town was swallowed up
missing people dead bodies Cults they
will come for you in the night and leave
you empty
and just when it seemed like things
couldn't get any worse things went
bloody dark
foreign
[Music]
cultists call them gods
unimaginably powerful vampires ruling
over redfall
[Applause]
the hollow man bloody Tom miss whisper
the black Sun
Gods created by science but how do we
stop them
[Music]
the only way to find out is to delve
into the darkness
time to take back red Falls
[Music]
is my life's work
foreign
[Music]